i want to start off
by saying this on record i've said this
on the radio
yeah but i've never i've never said it
in your presence because we haven't
really seen each other
the way you handled i heart letting you
go
yeah was [ __ ] incredible like i think
and i said i don't know if you have you
heard or heard or if anybody told you
when i was on the air
when i went on the air the day after day
and day after you left i heart
i went on the air at 7 00 p.m sharp
and i said the way boule cave has
handled this situation
is bar none and moving forward nobody
could tell me anything about boulay kev
yeah man i think you know you and i
would have these talks
off all the time i mean all the [ __ ]
time
and you know what another thing too
people are like hey didn't you know
i'm like bro you know how many times
they hit me without me and you got the
same kind of call we thought
you missed doc's call and we thought we
were both done i thought
i was known but this is the thing people
was like man did you get a heads up i
said bro you know how many times i've
been told like having fire kev you
better talk to him
you know what i'm saying like yeah i
think i think well what's crazy is i got
resigned
in april during the pandemic they
resigned me for three years
and that don't mean [ __ ] right no so
then i got that call in december and
then i called you
yeah and then while i was talking to you
doc was calling you
yeah and then you clicked over and you
said you said oh yeah it's over bro
yeah that was a laugh you called me back
like hey i'm good over here why don't
you talk about it
right before right before i click over
to get the doomsday call
kev is like yo it's over bro
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] yeah i mean look it for me
you know i mean
i was i was already kind of
over doing radio the traditional way the
way that we were doing it
yes and it's probably safe to say that
had been the case for a while
yeah so for me i looked at uh getting
let go by iheart and real 923
first of all shout out to doc winner
because i know that it wasn't i mean he
you know it wasn't like he was like yo
you're fired we're not [ __ ] with you
yo we got we're letting go of some
people because of the budgets this
pandemic
pandemic yeah you know i got paid on my
severance so
and again like for me it was more
it cleared my my time it cleared my
clear you know what what i realized
during the pandemic when you and i were
doing our show from zoom
how much other [ __ ] i could be doing if
i had more flexibility to not be
physically at the radio station every
day
you know i was busting plays moving
around i was in mexico on zoom with you
doing the show it was like yo this is
kind of fire
this pandemic [ __ ] kind of lit but it
but it also it also just kind of made me
realize like
man i want to you know i'd already been
to tooling with the idea of
doing a syndicated show i launched the
podcast
during the pandemic in june and it just
kind of like
me getting let go was amazing i'm not
and i i
at zero like not a single time
did i ever feel some type of way no
because people get fired and they get
all [ __ ] mad
and it's like ego [ __ ] i literally was
like i gotta let go and my girl started
crying
and i was like why are you crying we're
about to turn the [ __ ]
up like this is great yeah you know like
i get i get to get paid until
for the next [ __ ] four months and now
i can just double down on
what i was gonna try to do anyway yeah
so yeah you know and i think like for
anybody who's watching this like
but i think no i was gonna say like just
know like
if you're in radio or you're anywhere
like
it's not in your best interest
if someone lets you go because of
[Music]
financial purposes
if it's not personal don't make it
personal it should never be personal
yeah you always say that
all the time we've seen a lot of people
leave that current
radio station and they take things
personal and then guess what happens
you burn a bridge yeah i don't i don't
believe in taking anything personal
three
three rules i live by all the time be
undeniable bring value don't take [ __ ]
personal
but that's all that aside though even
even even though you didn't take it
personal and you'd like
i'm about to turn you looked at this
opportunity yeah the way you
handled it though was [ __ ] fire
like i don't know i don't know that that
that doesn't happen a lot
right especially like it's like hey no
like go do your [ __ ]
yeah for me it was like i'm just like i
talk with i talk with doc i talk with ao
and i i was like yo it's it's all good
like it's all good you know i released
my statement
and i'm obviously rooting for you and
chuck i love you guys
uh you know you guys this is meant to be
homegrown radio needs to be on every
night in la this is something you guys
have worked
forever for and like yo this is great
everyone wins here
i feel like i'm winning you know a lot
of people from the outside looking to
probably
go fight i don't give a [ __ ] i don't
care what other people think and then
you guys get to have your shot at nights
together yeah you guys are
you know been friends for however long
everyone won